Bà sẽ được khám sức khỏe định tiền miến tý, ít nhất một lần 1 năm, hoặc biến và nụ về tý cơ bản và năm 2018.
Đây là một trong những mục tiêu của Mỹ quyết bệ mì hai, vừa được bộ chính trị và anh, nhằm tăng cường vào vệ, trong sop và mất cơ sức khỏe tần dân.
Vậy lộ chính các mục tiêu này sẽ thế nào?
Tưởng năm 2018, hơn một trong trường giân sẽ được khám sức khỏe miến tý, ít nhất một lần 1 năm, với các dịch vụ cơ bản như loại app, sách nhiệm mẫu và khám tần quát.
Mỗi người sẽ có sổ xức khỏe định tự theo rõ xuất đời.
Thứ trưởng ít tế chân văn thấn cho biết, ngăn xe tân khoảng 2.5 nghìn tý đồng 1 năm để bảo đam chư chính này.
Tâm 2 nghìn khúc trong 2 biệ bài, mối trạm ít tế cấp sả sẽ có ít nhất 1 đến 5 xí,
đi lệ khám trước bệnh vào hiệu ít tế tại dưới sả đặc trên 2 mươi phần chăm.
Nếu nếu nghìn khúc trong 3 mươi, bình biển tý cơ bản, tức những chỉ bị năm trong gọi bảo hiệu ít tế sẽ được miệt bị hoàn toàn.
Đồng thời hướng tới báo khu vào hiệp ý tế tỏng dân sau khi mức chính từ 20.5, tức đường chỉ lắm về năm triệu người hiện nay theo báo hiệp sấu Việt Nam.
Tâm nhìn hăng nghiên khúc trong 4.5, viện năm hướng tới 1 trường sống chất lượng.
Châu cao chú bình trẻ em và thành thứ miền tăng tối theo 1 phẩy năm cm.
Tối họ chú bình đã bẩy 5 phẩy năm tối trong đó số năm sấu khảy mạnh tối theo, sống mới tạm năm.